like know what rock did you know did you
cry like a baby
I [ __ ] [ __ ] I took it like a fight I
took em up there solo just [ __ ] how
long do you have the doctor he was only
nine it was a big dogs yeah them for
nine you know mom yeah it's tough yeah
yeah it's one of those shitty [ __ ]
thing yep
but you know it's part of being a dog so
but that said John you put down a dog
you said he seems super sad just now
oh yeah that's like ya know I know he
did a good job
like damn John's got a dog there's some
deep [ __ ] there's a spot broke his heart
is 14 you go dust 3:17 everybody it's
gary vay-ner-chuk every 17 of the
askgaryvee show and Dustin wants to him
to put the it's a dust way to interrupt
the show bro but but but I love it it's
great to have Michael here I'm gonna let
him introduce himself in a second but
for everybody who's watching on
Instagram you need to go to Facebook and
YouTube if you want to ask a question
for everybody on Facebook and YouTube
the way you ask a question is putting in
your phone number in the comments
section with some cymatics of what
you're kind of gonna go with the
question and just to establish thematics
Michael why don't you tell everybody who
you are what you do and and then I'll
jump in ask some questions and we'll jam
and try to bring some value sweet my
name is Michael chernow I am a
restaurant entrepreneur been at it for a
long time
born and raised in Manhattan New York
City born and raised born and raised
where'd you live
87th and first as a kid loved it and
then bounced right by a baseball card
store up there Alex is MVP let's go
let's go you both cards there's very few
people that know about Alex's MVP I'm
sneaky that's so [ __ ] cool um okay
yeah so I grew up I grew up up there you
know growing up in in New York in this
in Manhattan sort of like how old are
you 38 okay keep going just want to
context of what timing you know growing
up in the it really growing up in the
90s right I was born in 80 but but like
I was coming to my I was coming into my
own in the 90s I was 10 but I was still
I was dude I was you know I was in New
York man you get exposed much young Rick
you get exposed much younger you know
and how young were you when you walked
the street of New York by your full self
like to school or so like truly but
truly by yourself of length that is
actually like like I don't know when I
walked to school in sixth grade and it
was like my like it was far I was okay I
was like now I'm grown so I I admire my
parents you know I love my [ __ ]
parents course you know I had somebody I
loved my [ __ ] parents but yeah might
be one of the great t-shirt can we make
you shirt actually
yo team can somebody you gotta Johnny I
want to make a t-shirt I love my [ __ ]
parents I love my [ __ ] parents and
then I want the butt to be big I better
get a [ __ ] quote on that [ __ ] might
get a little good so I so Mike my
element I went to PS 158 elementary
school on 76 feet in your calves big
public school and I was on the bus from
86th Street into 79th Street when I was
like straight up in third fourth grade
yep my sister and I yeah and so I was
going to school pretty young and then I
probably started stepping on the train
and I was like fifth sixth grade and I
was and I remember very clearly
specifically around this time July 4th
going down to Canal Street as like a
young buck kid 12 years old to get
fireworks and like walking down like
back alleys you know the Chinese guys
get you on the street and then they walk
you into the back alley to the Italian
guys and that's where like the [ __ ]
blockbusters are you know like and I
remember being it says this L like as a
kid you just grow up in the city and
Rick
quick quick you're like you're like
you're like equal twelve-year-old
cousins are in Jersey or like Long
Island or Connecticut look and they're
like [ __ ] just stepping on a
skateboard exactly with like a helmet on
and they all they all were and
yes so what anyway so so I got my first
you know I mean I like I I [ __ ] taken
your content I [ __ ] love your content
and and I and I you know I love it
because it's [ __ ] real and it speaks
to me and I've like came out of the womb
sort of with this hustler mentality like
I was selling my [ __ ] toys like as
early as I can remember and a good
student no terrible
I wasn't terrible I was probably like uh
75 to 80 straight you know what I mean I
was like I'll be like a like a B so it
came easy to you it came easy because
you I don't I hated [ __ ] homework I
was not a study guy and you know I went
to college for six months and [ __ ]
just I thought this was the biggest
biggest waste of time honestly and
that's not for everybody by the way it
was like for me it was like I went here
went because first what your age group
there weren't that many viable
alternatives back then second of all for
your parents well let me let me press a
little bit so so I grew up my household
was pretty I'd it wasn't the best
upbringing right I had a tough
relationship my father even though I'm I
love him and he's gone now but you know
I had a population it was tough and they
were together they were together and but
he needed tough he made it tough and it
wasn't that he was strict he was just a
straight-up [ __ ] like that's the
bottom line right he was a straight-up
[ __ ] but he taught me three
incredible things that I'd love to
mention it's the point okay so the three
things that my pops taught me were
really important and could potentially
be controversial right now so like and
and I never would have thought of this
ever until somebody brought it up to me
but my father taught me that you know
when I was probably three or four years
old we were walking into an elevator I
remember it like was yesterday for good
walking into an elevator and my father
grabbed me by the back of my neck pulled
me out looked at me put his hands on my
shoulders looked at me and you said you
never ever walk in front of a woman ever
and like that should just stuck with me
like so and it stuck with me to this
very day he scared the daylights out of
me at that age and so like I you know
and I've passed it on to my sons right
like listen to your point listen the
world evolves you know political
correctness proper Ness evolution it's
all great but I think look we cast so
much judgment on each other what a lot
of people when they're over cynical - to
your point not thinking that that could
be a bad thing for the you know I have a
friend who who also got mad at me around
opening the door says if something went
down and the conversation I had with her
was like look iris Mazel Tov like I
respect your opinion I'm like you also
have to think about how that trickles
down like you're worried about the
semantics what about the macro treating
like respect and things of that nature
so you know to your point so okay so so
so that was so that was Vaughn thing and
that [ __ ] and that [ __ ] and that [ __ ]
has stuck with me to this very day my
wife hates it like I'll be standing at
like Bloomingdale's and I'm holding a
[ __ ] door I gotta change and by the
way you see me doing an elevator right
like sometimes it takes like an extra
minute cuz I'm you but that's just who
it is and it and honest right you notice
it it's not it's not just women for me
it's just like in general like it's just
like I just [ __ ] do that and let ik
dudes like John you know go ahead I just
Rasim for no reason poor guys just
sitting there filming Instagram just
having a good day go ahead and and and
he he he taught me when I give a
handshake to squeeze and and look in
someone's eyes he was an old-school dude
all it's cool to old-school pops tough
on him his pops was an animal and my and
his pops my grandfather is still alive
97 kickin and was he awesome to you was
it one of those clashes kid were animal
to you to not animal in this the way he
was an animal to my dad like that's what
the cliche story is right like toughest
[ __ ] on the dad but like went through
the process and played the grandson
different there's all sorts of versions
I was just curious
ya know he I mean you know he's done
some ill [ __ ] to me my grandfather that
like are like like unacceptable like
just [ __ ] you know like took me in a
room when I was I was a bad kid
like I turned I like I'll get I was a
bad I was a bad kid hand stealing like
fighting like all sorts of [ __ ] I was
I really nice like like you see them
like I was just like I could I was a bad
kid I moved out of my parents house
anyway speeding up I moved out to my
parents out of my parents house when I
was 15 and I was sort of like on the
street you know bouncing around just
getting after the rug dealing yes just
getting after the hustle whatever - I
had I had a number of side hustle so my
first job was at 13 delivering [ __ ]
couch potato videos then I got a job on
rollerblades by the way I'm just like
sane then I got a job at a restaurant
crush with the ladies but um you know I
got a job right down the street
delivering food at a restaurant and
that's when I was like wow I could like
I loved this environment like I loved I
loved the noise I love the just like the
accident I need the action and that's
like do you know that I literally play
music top speed in like I you know much
noise I need at all you guys know like
so those ones too quiet here noise is
the only thing I'm comfortable in I'm
gonna throw some crazy I'm having a
problem because New York City's starting
to feel slow and I'm like if that's true
like I'm gonna end up in some weird town
in Asia like that's the only other place
yeah like I'm like I'm a master I'm like
[ __ ] I'm enough to move to China yeah
you might have to relate to like like
the center like crosswalk in Japan yeah
you know like that wine that you see all
pickleball pick a ball but so so I got a
job and that and that's when I knew that
like I can get money like I can just get
money and like and and and I always kind
of thought that way I had a dog-walking
[ __ ] business when I you know before I
got my first real job
and then one thing led to the next and I
got hooked up with this nightclub
situation where they were like handing
out flyers and back in the day there was
no email right so likes it it was it was
like handing out flyers promoting in
front of the club so I connected with
all these promoters and then and that
was a skills listen sending out email
versus handing out flyers in real life
to people you're talking about two very
different skill sets well they also
thought it was really funny to have a 15
year old kid on a skateboard outside of
the night group so at 15 I looked 9 what
did you look like it fit I looked really
young too but like like I was een
probably like an 18 year old attitude
what
yeah for sure I was always the youngest
and I was like good in the room like I
just know I could sit in the room and I
could sit with anybody really and I
don't know where they came from
Delta with girls and guys did you like
crush with both were you like better
with at that point with guys and girls
better with girls than guys like that's
always an interesting question to me
that's a semantics of that charisma that
I'm oh we isn't that an interesting
question because there's versions of you
know where I'm going with this right
there's some people that do better than
one with the other or the reverse you
know it's really it is an interesting
question I'd actually never [ __ ]
thought of that question you know what's
funny about it I've never asked it but
I've been thinking about it for the last
year and I'm super pumped I just
delivered it and I'm pumped with the way
you responded to it and now I'm pumped
to keep going down the rabbit hole of
what does it actually mean so anyway
answer it at that point so I will say
this probably you know I I was in high
school young cuz I'm like my birthday's
at the end of the year and October
October 21st yeah so like so III I was
it I we were tricky right because the
November people were older actually oh
yeah maybe that's right cuz that was
that cutoff so I was always the youngest
in in in in my class and I remember so
clearly in my freshman year of high
school I was 13 and like really for the
first time some some chick took me aside
and she was like you're hot and I was
like like there's another there's a
whole nother world as important to me
grab bag it's interesting that like that
like lit you up man that just like it
just made me realize that like way like
things were about to have yeah yeah
there's like there's like there's like a
whole nother yep like element that's
like and and you know and like that
yes so anyway so I had this this this
this hustle with the with the the
handing out flyers and then I linked up
with the with the promoters and they all
needed all their envelopes stuffed and
there was like ten of them and I I
started like sort of hanging out inside
this Club stuffing these envelopes and
then I got all my friends to stuff the
envelopes and so now I had this like
ring of like envelope stuffing promoting
like things going on and and then I and
then I started working in the club and
you might have to also started a little
stuffing mafia t-shirt but you know it
taught me a lot and I you know and for
whatever reason like I just always had
these weird little side hustles but all
through high school and I don't know how
I [ __ ] did it but I didn't live at
home I like lived on in other people's
houses but I stayed in high school and I
graduated high school right so which is
crazy friends parents took you in in
theory for periods of time no because
remember I was always the youngest so I
told our kids that like had apartments
or had NYU dorms you know the first
place I moved the way cooler version of
where I was going with it
like it's one thing to like be like the
second son in a house and it's like a
nice family it's way different to be
staying in college to where people that
are 18 with their own apartment when I
when I moved out of my parents that's
when you grow up
[ __ ] it fast fast I think doubt and I'm
not right into Alumni Hall and why you
join the nice and third literally 15 I
knew this girl likes to party
like you know and I was just like yo I'm
moving in and she was like okay let's do
it and so I moved in she said radical go
ahead so anyway so I did bad then I like
you know I I lived in some crazy loft on
Horatio Street I just like I just ended
up in crazy places and and do you think
you should make a movie I don't know if
I should make a movie but I like I
definitely will write a book at some
point I feel like you should make them I
think one day you should produce a movie
that's softly based on your life right
because you need to embellish it for the
silver screen change some [ __ ] that kind
of has like a basket
all Diaries vibe I love that movie meet
Emily [ __ ] me out this that one girl in
that movie just out my life is that
movie cuz I you know I want everything I
became a man who is that with Leo anyway
so but but there is like a light at the
end of the tunnel obviously in this
story and and the experience and the
stories that I have from growing up in
New York City and I did that movie [ __ ]
you up
that was a it was like the coolest movie
that I never come out
III really well it [ __ ] me up because
I I like ended up struggling with drugs
I'd like towards you know like like what
when you of course the clue like you had
it somewhat under control like drugs is
a very simple game where were you in
that process when that movie came up in
the struggling part on the verge of the
struggling part or trying to get out of
this I was I was I was probably like
like it was that movie probably that
movie came out in like 90 what 899 feels
right so like that was when I was like
really I really knew that I was like
holy [ __ ] dude you've turned into this
animal like you've turned into this to
this to this guy it's like you know the
guy you promised yourself you would
never be that you would stop just
whatever I actually never promised
myself I'd be that guy because I like my
surroundings yeah you know strides like
you know cuz at the end of the day
though I always had a job like I never
did not have a job I always had a job
that makes it like yeah that's where
people get caught because if they're
lucky enough to love that it's the thing
they used to justify that they're good
pretty much and and also it was like a
have my cake and eat it too situation
like I got I worked in restaurants you
know restaurants and nightclub so I was
able to like live the life that like I
actually enjoyed which was [ __ ] going
hard and then also like develop my
rolodex I took with growing a network of
people anyway and I love people man like
people are like I I believe I believe
people are everything period and done
like you people that's probably
something that when you started
consuming or seeing some of my stuff
like we connected on that right because
a lot of people don't talk about that I
talk about it heavy dude it is it is
everything and if you and and in my
opinion and now I've
opened and you know I've opens 18
restaurants in my in my career and like
I look at it and I say like if you run a
business strictly on a P&L it's game
over
it's [ __ ] big old trouble like if
you're not playing life ends you ready
for this
I barely run on a piano I
I know that listening to you I know that
be clicking like I am so not interested
I only care about one thing will I make
payroll my interest in my P&L stops and
starts with can I pay my bills mm-hmm
yeah I I mean look i-i-i i think and and
it's probably because I was a technician
for like I was a technician for years
before I opened my first business right
I got my first job in a restaurant
either 12 or 13 I don't [ __ ] remember
but you know I didn't open my first
restaurant till I was 28 so and I was
the restaurant that you opened for whom
right before that what was the last stop
prior to your own so it was eight years
I spent in one spot in the East Village
and this guy was I mean it's it still is
one of the best places which is at Frank
restaurant the second half so like and
the beauty of that like I learned so
much money 228 22 28 and I learned so
much in that restaurant I learned how to
like talk about like getting out there
and and and like first of all getting a
PhD just in wildlife in real life
because there was really no management
so I was able to like I was really able
to manage my own [ __ ] and also I was the
thing I loved about like a lot of these
guys and gals that work on my team like
the cliche thing that everybody looks I
was like we need more structure I'm like
that's cool I'm like one day you will be
on a podcast talking about how awesome
it was of being able to actually do [ __ ]
with less structure there was the Emmy a
night look Frank I [ __ ] love you bro
know if you're listening to this [ __ ]
you know what I mean like you know there
was no structure and like I had to be
the guy to do it and and and the other
beauty of that place that is the
structure I hope Frank's right now
watching this and he's like that's the
structure [ __ ] like it's that's
the structure it's a different structure
see different structure it's the gray to
the black and white pretty much that's
it I love that it's the gray to the
black and white [ __ ] t-shirt
yeah so learned a [ __ ] I learned a [ __ ]
ton there and I also like really honed
my salesmanship they're like hey John I
apologize
Trouty with empathy you can't believe
how much [ __ ] in the first year or so
that you took for granted cuz I was
doing that part that you're like what
the [ __ ] right meaning like now that
you're at the top of a business all the
[ __ ] that every time you were an
employee even if you were a chief of
staff to me even as close as you got to
the son now that you're on the other
side of it you're like what the [ __ ]
right yeah that's what creating you know
a lack of structure gets you to right on
the edge and then you learned the next
part you needed in the first 24 months
up to your 30th birthday yeah why also
my fireman of your own [ __ ] I also you
know I like I became a man in that
restaurant you know what I mean like I
became a payment not only I become a man
just like every yeah in evolution yes
but like I got you know I mean I'm not
ashamed to say I'm sober 15 years I'm
sober long [ __ ] times you know what I
mean and so like I got and because of
Frank really Frank [ __ ] set me up but
like you know punched you in the face
punch me in the face the only way punch
me in the face and and and by the way
had the juice to do it and well he
basically was like you're fired bro like
I love you he's like I [ __ ] love you
and you're the best bartender I've ever
had and like I've never seen anybody
sell [ __ ] Quinn Torelli like you but
like your God yeah he was like you're
gone and I was like Frank you can't do
that to me because my job was and I was
an I like rowdy you're fired but like
that was it and and so he basically I
like I pretty much got on my [ __ ]
hands and knees and and I was like Frank
man you got it like this is like this is
what keeps me whole like this is what
males where you go with it and he was
like you got to show up to the rest
every morning at 8 o'clock and clean
with the porters and call me and if you
call me a minute past 8 you're [ __ ]
gone and you got to get sober so he went
with the yes because I've you know I've
seen both work things that he went with
the yes made it painful and created a
rule yes said yes made it painful and
created a singular real and by the way I
just want to say something about that
like I don't think that that I know from
my experience now like you cannot make
anybody do [ __ ]
you just can't like you can you can beat
the [ __ ] out of somebody and like
literally to a pulp and be like you have
to do this or or I'm gonna continue
beating you and if they're not if
internally soulfully they're not
interested in doing it it's a wrap
there's no shot it's a wrap and that's
just like and I'm I don't know much
right but I do know that like I tried to
[ __ ] what's really you know what's
also awesome is you were tired at that
point I was like that's the answer to
that question to like the only time
people make that flip in anything
forget about even addiction even like
career changes even relationships it's
just when your that's it you're just
tired
I was you know what I mean I was done
and it was just like I just needed that
one last yeah yeah you were you were at
that 23 year old version of yourself the
20 year old version of yourself wasn't
dud the flame is hot yeah you would've
been like [ __ ] you Frank I'm gonna build
a restaurant across the screen kill your
mother what it is pretty much but like
the beauty the beauty of it all was I
was able to really stay I like you know
through that time moving out like I just
had this this passion this drive to like
do [ __ ] and not be a deadbeat and not be
a bomb yep and and I got I got my [ __ ]
together and then I I like I you know I
went to culinary school I did that and
Frank that was actually I act I said hey
Frank after I was sober for a year I was
like dude you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
go out there and do this like I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm not saying I'm gonna do it
right now but I'm gonna go out and do it
and five yeah whatever it was I was like
one day I'm gonna do it and and he was
like and I don't know you know I I don't
know what he would say now you know or
how he felt then but he basically was
like
I don't know if you got it in you I love
it and I was like best [ __ ] thing he
could say to you that was the best thing
he said tonight cuz I just went out and
[ __ ] Oh murdered that was like that
was like do you know that I manifest
people doing that to me that the one
thing in my life that all this stuff
that's going on with me that is
heartbreaking is that now people think I
can do things and I'm like literally
probably gonna go to Japan and sit in
that corner because like literally like
the sneaker deal was a hundred percent
that I'm like okay this is something
nobody thinks I'm gonna be able to pull
off they're gonna think I'm stretching
here mm I'm reaching like like somebody
telling me I can't is my oxygen me to
bro
me too and and and honestly you know
like I sometimes I wish it wasn't you
know what I mean because like I don't I
there's never well there's there's a
second part to it when I fail after
Caleb told me that I can't make films I
actually don't judge myself and that's
where your [ __ ] unstoppable if you're
completely driven by that you can't and
then you actually win both ways because
when you win you're like told you
[ __ ]
or when you lose you're like yeah I
can't hear you're booing well then
you're [ __ ] on stuff oh so that's it
that's the first thing he wants to it I
you know I was sitting down with a good
friend of mine um a couple of weeks ago
and this dude is a he's a he's an
amazing dude I mean he's a complete
lunatic and he knows it but he said some
[ __ ] to me that I was like wow that
might have been the most sort of
righteous thing I've ever heard you say
and he was like Mike the the answer to
happiness or the key to happiness is
accepting the moment done and I was like
and he was like that doesn't mean you're
gonna be [ __ ] happy all the time
but it means if you can actually accept
a moment and not fight the moment not
like like try to control when shit's not
going your way and actually accept it
receive it and [ __ ] respond like that
is happiness because you're not gonna be
constantly in a battle with yourself and
everything around you because you have
zero [ __ ] control you know where my
head
goes on that which even gets more like
which is a funny build so I hear that
I'm like yeah that dude nailed that
what's absolutely right and then I was
like [ __ ] man and for me on sim serious
[ __ ] bro I'm even the other like I can't
tell you how much I like when shits bad
I but that but that's it don't actually
think I like losing more than winning I
know and I've heard you say that I think
I'm like you know I'm working through my
own [ __ ] here I'm like this is [ __ ]
crazy I hate the Yankees and the Rangers
now cuz they've won me a championship
and I've got nothing but [ __ ] dead
passion for the Knicks and Jets cuz I
haven't like all the people they go out
these mother the reason I'd make fun of
all those Steph Curry [ __ ] Jersey
kids is they [ __ ] they need
affirmation from a third party they jump
on bandwagons I'm jumping off bandwagon
I didn't even get to enjoy the Yankee
dynasty after eating shimmies and early
90s because I have to [ __ ] Charlie
Hayes caught the ball I was out I have
not watched a complete Yankee game since
1996 I don't even know what Jeter did
mm-hmm
I don't even know what Jeter did cuz you
were just [ __ ] has it checked out yeah
because I like losing more than winning
how do you beat somebody like that you
don't I believe that
and I don't that's for that like that in
itself right there what you just said is
in an essence
accepting the [ __ ] like you like it's
not believe I believe that it's not like
you're like going into the ring and
you're like I'm gonna lose you're like
I'm gonna go into the ring I'm gonna
[ __ ] put it on someone and if I lose
it's all good not only is it all good
and this is where it gets real
interesting hat tip to that [ __ ] guy
like he brie me I'm pissed
I remember when I was doing great with
investing and like people were trying to
really floss on me Facebook and I was
like what about Chris Sacca what about
Scott Belsky
they did it better mmm-hmm during the
same era where all started in the
general same place so like like I just
like the merit of the game the journey I
hate watching people in the restaurant
business [ __ ] on the guy or gal that's
beating them currently look at the [ __ ]
are you spending all your time [ __ ]
on somebody who's
executing like who does that everybody
in the restaurant world in every world
in every world where people compete
whoever's currently winning is getting
whispered behind because people do that
you know it's weird you know and maybe
it maybe it maybe I'm just [ __ ]
oblivious to the [ __ ] I believe in the
restaurant world and I think it's animal
abuse
maybe at my level you know like like the
super high level guys like the guys that
are doing like 60 million in revenue out
of a restaurant maybe they're like I'm
gonna put a dagger through my [ __ ]
co-tenants heart they're not saying that
they're just like whoever's in a white
heat moment Shake Shack
there's haters by the way that's not
actually where I'm going yes I'm
actually talking about just competitive
banter mm-hmm like it's just it's not
even bad what you don't think katie has
said something about hardened you don't
think Westbrook has some words about
Paul George's game doesn't like it's the
game yeah and I'm just always curious
about that you know I like I mean look
dude I I am and I'm just I'm just I'm an
overly [ __ ] optimistic guy I'm the
guy truly cuz I just know that the
business of business is relationships
for me like I know my whole [ __ ] is
built on relationships everything it's
built on me actually you know what we've
gotten people like so enjoy this and
like just wish we're actually hanging
out more than what I normally do four
five two minutes please what your
business so so so anyway so I finished
culinary school I started to write I
started to think about what I was gonna
do and I wrote a wrote a business plan
with my with my best friend from child
miss plans yeah
none of these [ __ ] think about that
[ __ ] anymore this [ __ ] is real I [ __ ]
now they're called decks yeah but so
anyway so III I started writing a
business plan my boy from childhood who
actually got me my first restaurant job
dan dan holzman amazing
dude we partnered up we came with this
idea for the meatball shop and fourteen
regulars from Frank wrote me a check
look that makes sense
so like I'm mad that I wasn't going
there cuz that would have been a good
investment cuz some of that [ __ ] is like
hearing that that was the easiest check
those 14 people wrote and they all
[ __ ] did very well
yes they did yeah and when I think about
where I've done well it is that story
not when it made sense when you had
context for the EQ and the drive of the
human yeah I will the amount of good
investments I'm about to make over the
next 20 years is going to be staggering
cuz [ __ ] is getting clearer and do you
make your investments strictly based on
the [ __ ] person I'm about to yeah
that's why the sentence that just came
out of my mouth came out yeah because
what I did it was called Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr and when I thought it
was hot [ __ ] I started thinking I was a
VC they weren't as good so now I'm going
back to who the [ __ ] I am I love that
cuz that's that I mean I'm even more
interesting it's why I've eaten [ __ ] and
build an agency for 10 years I'm not
gonna do that I'm gonna homegrown all my
[ __ ] culture is [ __ ] everything and
and and and and you know and that's why
quite frankly so Eddy so so so 14
regular so you guys open the first place
open up a restaurant on on Stanton
Street and Lower East Side when February
10 2010 February 9 2010 so we're nine
and a half years old quickly so right
after the world melted right after that
like the pit yeah like the [ __ ] pit
what means you were ready in motion well
the beYOU know the beauty of the brand
yes I know we go to brand before we get
to that cuz that's what you're what
you're about to start to say I was in
motion as the world was crashing how do
you when Lehman's fell like the next day
were you like what dude it didn't even
run didn't even know didn't even [ __ ]
know I'm gonna scratch my I didn't even
have a [ __ ] computer like I had like
a desktop you know what I mean like I
didn't email you know what I'm saying
like I was like I was all EQ like that
was mild that was it period like oh yeah
I was that guy I get it and you'd like
[ __ ] on phones I just like feel like if
I can't shake the man's hand [ __ ] it
but like I was just that I just think
you know I was like not that guy and
then and then um and then that [ __ ] went
down and like you know I think I did I
wrote the plan and and and when we went
I remember when Daniel now we're talking
about and we were like man we got to
make this [ __ ] recession proof like we
got to make it so so valuable like it's
got to have such value that like people
are gonna call no matter what people got
to eat right so if you don't sell
something if you could sell something an
offer an environment and atmosphere that
people can get down with like play
biggie smalls and [ __ ] Sir bowls and
meatballs for five dollars with a smile
like who's not gonna want to get down
with that these dudes are like wait a
minute I'm going no they're like they're
they've all been your arms and that's
right and so and so how many locations
there's eight now so there's eight six
in the city one in DC one in Connecticut
we just opened up in Connecticut anyway
sorry and how are you thinking about the
expansion of that brand I think the
expansion of that brand is going to grow
concentric Li probably suburban markets
it's it's become you know I launched
that brand in the in the sort of you
know the people that I launched that
brand with are now you know wiped up
with kids you know I'm saying like
that's the truth right and they all live
in like Westport Connecticut or
something like that and that's why I
opened up with my sport Connecticut so
like we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
grow that brand I'm gonna follow them
all the way to retirement homes in
Florida but like that's like when you
say I believe in that [ __ ] and then and
then so so I built that I built out that
restaurant concept and then for four and
a half five years in I learned this was
an invaluable lesson for me I am really
good at creating brand building culture
developing teams and and just sort of
harnessing that when it comes to day to
day ops and like not all the logistics
not my thing it's just it's not that
it's not my thing I'm just not good at
it I'm not so it I was just about to ask
you you beat me to the punch line
because in that world it's super
interesting some people are capable at
it and hate it
some people like it just aren't capable
at it some so you just felt like I'm not
good at it I did it's not exactly yeah
I'm not a good you see for me you want
me like you
me as the frontman yeah like that's what
you want me to be on the sizzle and and
and and and and the team's like the
people yep need to be like that well the
the people love love they need like what
I've learned is that in order to in
order to move like make waves right like
I opened up a restaurant in New York
City where there's 24,000 restaurants a
thousand restaurants open and close
every [ __ ] day it's like in order to
make a wave you have to have a group of
people that are waving the flag period
like you just need to do that and they
need to wave the flag and the only way
to do that is through culture and the
only way to do that is through optimism
and listening and empathy and like being
like all the [ __ ] that you [ __ ] preach
like that is absolutely necessary in my
opinion in today's world and you could
say you know there's there's not
multiples you know people aren't selling
business you know restaurant business is
necessarily right now for seven billion
dollars but like that is if you can do
some great [ __ ] that is the way to do it
in my that is one of the more impressive
things that have happened on my team in
a long time so anyway so I learned I
learned my role I needed I needed to
know my role and my role was in that and
as the business grew it became much more
of an operational business and a
logistical business totem that was in
that was my turn my time to pass a baton
and be like guys I'm [ __ ] in this I'm
the biggest cheerleader but I'm gonna
zoom out and step back and create some
new [ __ ] because that's what keeps me
going
yep and so I did so I did I made that
call Daniel took on the CEO role I
assumed out and still a partner still
[ __ ] hoorah guy but I launched a new
business called Seymour's there's now
six of those in the city about four
years ago and you know that's that's how
I think I'm gonna go I'm what's the
biggest thing you've learned that you
were wrong about in launching Seymour's
because this is that transition what you
just went through I loved and like I
know how on fire you were at that moment
because much like you were ready at 23
you were ready when you launched
Seymour's like you you'd known you
weren't the operations guy for a while
so you know you hold that in now you're
not you're zooming out and boy did you
love that zoom out phase because you're
doing the appropriate thing everything's
going right now
this new baby that you're about to go
that you [ __ ] pumped the confidence
level is uncomfortable because you have
success you're more primed you have more
experience and then inevitably like any
business there's certain things that
didn't go the way you thought they were
gonna go on that like what's here we are
how many years late for so perfect a
great time to ask this question what
were you wrong about so it's a it's a
tough one right because cuz you're
crying
well I'm [ __ ] wrong about a lot of
[ __ ] but I like go for it [ __ ] I like
and I like to do a lot of do also in it
you know I'm in it so like it's a lot
easier it'll be a lot easier to answer
this question in seven years right now
well no I know what I did wrong what I
know what I do and I didn't do it wrong
in the beginning keep going I open I
launched Seymour's partner free I raised
money but I had no partners I had I had
a team of amazing [ __ ] people that
believed in a [ __ ] mission right like
they believed in me they believed in the
mission and we was demand what was the
mission the mission was to do great
[ __ ] things and serve sustainable
seafood but literally it was more about
an experience offer an accessible
seafood restaurant right a seafood
restaurant that you could [ __ ] walk
in and a pair of [ __ ] sneakers and
teeth in and jeans and spend 25 bucks it
didn't exist in New York for really
great fresh fresh fish and then also
just do some great [ __ ] out there and
and you know save the [ __ ] world
while you're at it good but um the I did
that without partners and and it was I
mean I opened the doors it was [ __ ]
bananas it was like I could not believe
like I surpassed my projections by like
one two you know bleh and that's big for
a small restaurant you know what I mean
and I and you know and it's an amplitude
[ __ ] partnership is just a hard thing
you know [ __ ] partnership and it's such
a tough subject to talk about because I
appreciate love and care about my
[ __ ] all the partners that I haven't
had but like I have learned an
invaluable lesson going into my next
venture which is yo dictatorships are
awesome
like yo you know if you're creative
dictatorships are awesome yeah I can
armed no two cooks in the kitchen it's
really hard no no it doesn't exist it
may sustain for a few seconds no yeah
and you know and so an only reason I
have had successful partnerships with my
dad family gets [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] is
because I don't value money otherwise
they would have been [ __ ] up real good
yeah and that's the truth too like that
and then I think what gets me into
trouble with the money guys is because I
just the money like I'm not in it for
the money right so Pablo why don't you
maximise and returns you're like I'm
like oh because this person's [ __ ]
dope yeah and we're gonna wait and like
and by the way you gotta wait they take
that answer
this person's dope and we gotta wait for
that to materialize so we catch it we're
covering more overhead than we need to
to make the most efficient short-term
ebay Dom [ __ ] yeah and I also
think that like if you are not focused
on the [ __ ] people you put in place
to go out there like the ops guys will
[ __ ] beat the marketing guy down like
beat them down and be like why are you
[ __ ] spending money on you can't
[ __ ] spend money in that Berlin and
and and the creative guys you can't
spend money we can't spend money on that
we can't [ __ ] spend money on a crew
to come in and create content and put
out some dope [ __ ] like we need to
[ __ ] save on our cogs and I'm like yo
my man like you've got nothing to
operate without marketing and innovation
that's why I'm the operator and the
marketing guy cuz this way I don't those
hear anything about anything about
anything
I'm being dead [ __ ] serious man of
course you're so right
so why most people lose and to your
point once you get that right up front
then if you really stabilize that then
you can milk brand in perpetuity and let
people operate the edges mm-hmm I care
so much man I care too much you know I
think that that is that's the best thing
that's happening to you the key is now
to always like understand it's just self
awareness now which is the evolution
you're going through I'm going through
like dude I'm freaking out currently
right now that I'm like not sure I like
money at all like it's been one thing
that I've sustained it till I do but I'm
like I'm really for the first time in my
life oh my god
you know what's so funny if I'm gonna be
in all these yeah where I'm like I just
don't like money I'm almost starting
like I'm really I'm about to do some
weird [ __ ] I can feel it or I'm about to
make a fuckload of money like one of the
two things is definitely more about to
buy the jet tomorrow you know so it just
it really is interesting though like I'm
going backwards like baseball cards yeah
you know what you know it's so I have
never met in my life
another man who loves [ __ ] garage
saling like I had to put my garage
saling game on the back burner because
like you just didn't even want people
that no no no I don't know I'm down with
it like yeah I'm down for people know my
wife despises garage saling despises of
that concept and like I bought a crib
upstate who's like I'm like there's a
garage sale every [ __ ] three
everywhere and so like we'd be riding
you you couldn't get one [ __ ] room
out of that deal dude listen listen I
understand like it's you know and still
like when you're running that hustle and
like having fun with it like I am on
what is the single best garage sale fine
look when I say that what did you find
that like was in so I'm gonna share
something with you which is crazytown so
this is like not a garage sale thing but
this is this is some [ __ ] so like I
built all the meatball shops I designed
all the meatball shops I did all that
[ __ ] and I did it all through garage
saleing an antique shop ceiling like I I
would go to like Brimfield right which
is happening right now I would go there
and I would spend 18 hours to the head
five days straight headphones on just
like opening up [ __ ] all the boxes
that people don't open up and finding
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying and like I
was I'm just like an a maniac when it
comes down to that rocks Ellie [ __ ] and
it probably comes from my father because
he was too but there's a house around
the corner from me it's a red bike as a
starting point to where you're going
with this I'm already fired up just like
I love my [ __ ] parents but when
you're talking garage sale talk if you
start a sentence with there's a house
abandoned massive and it's a one house
real quick just for everybody who's
listening an abandoned house story in
garage sale talk is like literally
investing in uber oh yeah literally good
so I and so uh and it's like right
around the corner from my house upstate
one house Road no other houses it's
called I'm not gonna say claim and I I'd
run by it and I look at it and I'm like
so brolic and big and just like I'm like
you're like I should I took me a year to
convince myself to just get them to just
say [ __ ] it I'm gonna break in the house
yeah - so my boy we roll up so fired up
right so really this is one of the
scenes and in the film
go ahead gonna we roll up pickup truck
not like on some like we're gonna roll
out with Matt yeah just in case yeah it
was a just-in-case pickup truck I know
what you're doing I get it so we roll up
and we break in and the thing is it's
not like home alone dude it's more like
just in case go ahead big house like
like big house and we walk in and and
the two of us were just like oh it was
filled I'm telling you like filled from
the fright you didn't know if there was
gonna be a completely empty house with
nothing I didn't know if I was walking
into the tales from the [ __ ] credit
or if I was walking into like holy [ __ ]
you just hit the lottery like I just
knew I knew that we were like you had to
go in
that's all you knew I just have to walk
into the place I don't know if I was
gonna die or walk away with some [ __ ]
you know
ill baseball's so go ahead so I walk in
and it's a super abandoned 100% of it
like straight up straight up abandoned
brick nobody [ __ ] is there okay
period for a long long time I don't know
for how punchline his story is a family
moved out the day before we go in there
and and it's filled if there's there's
there's just mad rooms everywhere
there's one and there's filled from the
floor to the ceiling just antiques I
like just piled on top of each other
just everywhere I'm like this is
impossible
like this is like totally unrealistic
and my boy is an antiques dealer and he
like I think he [ __ ] his pants the
minute we walk like literally I was like
bro like it was insane and and there was
rooms filled with books floor-to-ceiling
just book stacks book stacks of books
that's a book I did one bad thing good
you had to I did one bad thing I grabbed
a book that was the only thing I took
word to mother that was like wow like
that was the only thing I took that's
not too bad no I took one book Ernest
Hemingway man in the sea saw it I was
like to New York 15 year old one sent a
while
first edition holy [ __ ] I looked on eBay
as soon as I like you're much better man
to me I would have sat there with my
phone looking up everything but I would
have I would still be there right now so
there's so the crazy thing is there was
one room that we couldn't get into and
we were like oh this must be this must
be the and and you broke in trust me we
tried no no we couldn't get in we got
out completely into the we walked into
the back of the property and we looked
up and there were stacked Louis Vuitton
trunks in that room like vintage Louie
Vuitton trunks in that room anyway I did
you know what I mean it was nuts like we
looked in the window we saw the LV I
liked the brown leather and in like
those trunks and we were like holy [ __ ]
they've got the whole they got this
anyway so that's probably the craziest
but like I found so much [ __ ] dude you
know I've found I found so much [ __ ] and
so like I didn't even know that that was
your thing and then the minute you said
like garage I was like oh my god I got a
[ __ ] me I got it there's no one else
outside of my weird antique do you know
the best part for me is is is taking
something I'm genuinely passionate about
knowing there's tab buna surround it or
just not a huge culture around it and
then pushing it so hard that it be cut
like like do what you're doing it with
the baseball card bro I'm walking around
garage sales the coolest [ __ ]
at
like 23 year old you is out there now
like getting it and like giving me head
nods I having a can Griffey upper deck
first and you know 489 upper deck kangra
fear okie cards that I have do you have
now
none so I'm funny with my collection I
kind of don't have one like I'm in it
for the process mmm yeah got it the game
behind the hunt I'm surprised you don't
love fishing dude like I'm on you know
it's funny that's funny you said that I
don't love it but I kind of weirdly like
it like like like I kind of weirdly
liked it like every time I do it once
two three times a year I'm fairly in it
because the the game of garage saling is
going out there and like seeing what I
genuinely genuinely also like selling
things so like if I could grab a fish
out of the sea and then sell it to
Trouty for five bucks I'd probably like
it so much like like a hunt so you're
not only in it for the hunt you're in it
for the actual sale as well but not for
the money from the sale just just seeing
what you can get do you understand the
curiosity would you take one question
why right sorry
because bro you know why especially if
something has no value the challenge of
creating value like I might start
actually selling things in nature like
I've been thinking about this lately
this is really weird like going mushroom
foraging and selling them no cuz that
has value I'm thinking about starting a
store that is just random things I find
in the wild like a lot like a leaf it
might be those are the craziest thing
you've ever said like you say crazy [ __ ]
but that could might very well be the
the most off to chart you know what is
unbelievable about that Michael is that
I'm confident that it would do extremely
well that if I created a brand that the
store was selling one-off things in
nature like framed leaf
nope just leaf leaf right like rock with
weird imprint like like straight-up like
pseudo fossil [ __ ]
or just like kin from 43rd Street I just
have this weird feeling that somebody
can build a crazy brand and Shopify like
think about the aspect you see I see I
know I gotta say sound dude I gotta tell
you the most [ __ ] insane story of all
time this guy this was like as real as
it got I remember back in the day when
asked her placed the trains yes so back
in the day when Astor Place was actually
asked her place right there was a guy
that would set up shop by like my number
one favorite thing about New York by far
is that a 38 year old can sit here in
2019 be like when Astra place was
[ __ ] Astor Place meanwhile if we did
some library [ __ ] right now in 1986 in
the New York Post some guys like when
Astor Place Astor Place and in 1971 what
that is my favorite thing about New York
so good and I like I wonder if it still
actually happens right like I don't know
I mean when I'm getting so soft bro that
in 2057 somebody's gonna be like in 2019
in New York like oh it was crazy like
people weren't hugging you dude there
was a guy listen there was a guy who
used to set up shop on the street and he
goes ah and he had a sign that said I'm
about to sell you some [ __ ] word he was
he had jars of [ __ ] people bought I was
like I mean it was like I remember I'm
I'm gonna I was like this camera I'm
gonna I might actually do this like I'm
thinking about this I might start a
brand called like Earth spelled like in
a weird way and it's a Shopify and I'm
just gonna pick up random [ __ ] on earth
and price it right some badass copy
about it make a little micro video and
do a million a year sell it of course I
will now but I'm gonna do it pseudo
incognito and nobody will now the
concepts out [ __ ] blue it
I am so obsessed to doing something in
my life that nobody knows that has
anything to do with me to eliminate all
excuses that I used my platform to do it
and just blow everybody
[ __ ] mind and just be like that was
me like six years later I like that idea
isn't that clever that is why is the New
York night scene so [ __ ]
besides the answer everyone gives which
is money took over at any dork can buy a
[ __ ] table
cuz rents gone I word I worked at like I
mean I went to the ton on the limelight
when I was young young young yeah and I
worked at life that was a nightclub that
I worked out when I was young you know
people have to I don't I don't go to
clubs anymore I haven't gone out and so
long year years and years so like I'm
like the wrong guy cuz I don't know how
bad it is but I can only imagine it's
not bad it's bad it's that nobody here
can speak to the desperation of going
somewhere this Saturday night that has
been eliminated from the youth lexicon
in New York you know I think maybe how I
mean I think in New York at that time
the celebrity scene was a little bit
grittier and the celebrity drew the
celebrity scene drove it like like when
I was first like the first thing that I
ever wanted to do in the nightlife was
go to sky sky bar remember that place so
like that was like the first thing I
wanted I wanted to go see [ __ ] I
wanted to see like Leonardo DiCaprio and
he was yeah whoo and like what they were
smoking yeah and I'm saying and Kate
Moss yeah I was like and they were just
like get like out there you know what I
mean and like who knows like I don't
think that there's like I don't know
what that celebrity clique is like right
now Plus everyone's a celebrity yeah I
guess so and at oh you know what it is
maybe ah I mean this is a theory it
could it could be wrong but lettuces but
it's just not exclusive anymore there's
zero exclusivity everything is tracked
and traced and and documented and and
and yeah and also leads to different
behavior when you know like they're you
know like like you know what I mean like
there is no there is no uncertainty when
you walk into the VIP room
how did what is metal right now 1987
same [ __ ] like yeah everything has to be
softer right like that's just that
punchline like that's the good that's
good in some ways and not I mean you
know it's the same thing like your your
your I you know the hip-hop game is
definitely different dude like it's just
definitely different like I grew up
listening to NAS and wu-tang and mob
deep and you know black moon and like
that chick man how good is black moon
probably one of the best albums of all
time diggin it like I think so but like
I mean I'm my hip-hop interest I like
when I work out I listen to all the new
[ __ ] but like when I'm at home listening
to hip-hop my interest stopped after
like 96 that's what happens it's the
same reason that there's some 70 year
olds only listening to [ __ ] The
Rolling Stones
like that's a game I don't know man I
think that there's I promise you that's
the game you think you think it's all
but it block yeah but listen dudes like
the whole entire the the the sound
changed drastic everything changes yeah
do you know what a restaurateur from
1947 thinks about a meatball place I
want let's leave it at let's leave it at
that bro thank you so much this was one
of my favorite times you usually I say
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
you keep watching we'll keep hanging out